starting off this our Stephanie in Idaho
hi Stephanie how are you I am doing
great Dave how are you doing better than
I deserve what's up well it's almost tax
season and actually it falls right with
my husband's bonus it's coming with his
job and we've got about thirty thousand
in debt total about sixty five to seven
sixty-five hundred to seven thousand
that is a car we bought last earlier
last year and the rest of it is student
loans between myself and my husband and
I'm just we're just not sure whether we
should throw it at the car or throw it
at our student loans oh I should
probably mention a about a thousand of
that is hospital bills from our dog our
daughter but that doesn't accumulate
interest so good doesn't matter if it
accumulates interest or not you list all
of your debts smallest to largest and
you pay them off in that order as fast
as you can
okay so your smallest debts would be all
the medical bills they'd be gone
and how much are you getting in total
between the tax return and the bonus you
said we estimated about seven thousand
so enough to pay off the car okay we're
on pay off the smallest debts first so
what is it what's your smallest student
loan oh my husband hasn't like nitpicked
down I think we've got one of his is
down to $1,000 from one year yeah and
you know just up from there okay
just needs to list them out it's not
it's not by category it's by loan so
nitpick them pull them apart and make it
make a solid list of every single debt
individually and list them out in the
order of smallest to largest and go as
far down that list as you can go and if
it doesn't quite pay the car off it's
not going to it's going to just pay a
big chunk on it then that you're gonna
be really hammering on the car from that
point forward and knocking it out I
assume you're actually working this plan
and you're on a budget and you're
throwing extra money at your debt all
the time anyway right oh yeah okay all
right and how much extra
are you throwing at your debts oh the
plan is 500 once we got our emergency
fund back up back up to 1,000 yeah we
had a small accident with the new car
and we had to get that taken care of
good okay and so you got to get that
back up to 1,000 what's your household
income combined we're probably at close
to 40,000 okay I work part-time I don't
have a set salary good gotcha and how
much debt do we have total including
these hospital bills of $7,500 car and
the student loans just under 30,000 okay
all right
well if we throw 7 at 30 that leaves us
23 and you do feel like 5th you do $500
a month plus regular payments that's got
you on about a 3-year schedule because
500 hours a month is $6,000 a year but
you're paying regular payments as well
yeah yeah so and the snowball and I
think you'll find more money to throw
with this as you go along to so my guess
is you're going to be out of debt
between two and three years 100% except
your house good good well that but the
point is how quick can we knock off 30
making 40 and throwing $7,000 in bonuses
and so forth and tax return now if
you're getting a tax refund that means
you're paying too much in out of your
monthly check and you need to adjust
your w-2 so that you don't have a refund
any more you do not want a refund
because if you get a $2,000 refund that
means that you've been giving them
almost $200 a month too much out of your
check and then they give it back to you
and act like Santa Claus lives in
Washington or something and I know Santa
Claus and I can promise you he doesn't
live in Washington he doesn't even like
Washington he just has to go there
because he's Santa Claus but other than
that you know you don't want to sit you
don't want send money to Washington
interest-free and you know they're
paying you no interest it's an
interest-free savings account with the
KGB I mean the IRS and so you don't want
to over with home
and get back a refund so adjust your w-2
to where you're bringing where you have
no taxes owed but no tax refund and all
of you need to look at that this time of
year you're starting to get your w-2s
and your you know your tax statements
and so forth in your mailboxes right now
and you need to look at that and you
need to adjust it so that you can have
this proper the proper withholding you
are not required by law to over withhold
a matter of fact it's just indicates
you're not doing math well but a lot of
people do a lot of people do give some
comfort to have a savings account that
has a zero interest on it hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh
[Music]